MESA, ARIZONA.
AND REMEMBER, MESA IS JUST 150
MILES FROM THE U.S./MEXICO
BORDER, A LOCATION WHERE MORE
THAN 5,000 MIGRANTS HAVE THEIR
SIGHTS ON.
AND TODAY THE MEXICAN GOVERNMENT
PERHAPS FARING RETRIBUTION FROM
PRESIDENT TRUMP, TRIED TO BLOCK
THE GROUP FROM CROSSING INTO THE
MEXICO GUATEMALA FRONTIER.
BUT THE CROWD BROKE DOWN THE
GATES AND STARTED STREAMING IN.
THE POLICE USING PEPPER SPRAY,
BUT NOT AFTER MANY GOT THROUGH.
NOW WE SPOKE EXCLUSIVELY TONIGHT
WITH A MEXICAN OFFICIAL WHO TOLD
US THE FOLLOWING.
THE MIGRANTS ARE USING WOMEN AND
SOME PREGNANT AND CHILDREN AT
THE FRONT OF THIS LINE IN AN
EFFORT TO INTIMIDATE THE MEXICAN
POLICE.
AND THE SAME OFFICIAL RELAYED TO
US THAT THERE ARE CURRENTLY
1,000 MEXICAN FEDERALES.
REINFORCEMENTS ARE BEING SENT IN
AS WE SPEAK.
AND MANY OF THE PEOPLE INSIDE
THE CARAVAN GREW VIOLENT TODAY,
INJURYING POLICE OFFICERS WHO
THEMSELVES HAVE NO WEAPONS
EXCEPT SHIELDS AND THEY DO HAVE
SOME BATONS IF THINGS GET BAD
AND TEAR GAS.
HE CLOSED SAYING THE FOLLOWING,
WE WILL NOT ALLOW OUR COUNTRY TO
BE LITERALLY INVADED FROM THE
SOUTH.
IT IS CRITICAL NOW TO TAKE A
STAND.
MEXICO HAS ITS OWN INTEREST IN
STOPPING THESE CARAVANS FROM
FLYING THROUGH MEXICO.
AND WHAT YOU SEE RIGHT NOW IS
NOT FROM THE CARAVAN, BUT TAKE A
LOOK AT THIS VIDEO.
THIS IS YESTERDAY MORNING AT
3:30 A.M. IN YUMA, ARIZONA.
YOU CAN SEE FOUR DIFFERENT
GROUPS OF ILLEGALS CLIMBING OVER
THE BORDER WALL, DROPPING RIGHT
INTO THE UNITED STATES.
AND AS PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID LAST
NIGHT, THIS COULD BE THE
ELECTION OF THE CARAVAN.
AND I WANTED TO BRING IN RIGHT
NOW FORMER HOUSE SPEAKER NEWT
GINGRICH.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE TONIGHT, A
BIG NIGHT.
LET'S START WITH THIS CARAVAN
ISSUE.
THE PRESIDENT SAID THIS COULD BE
THE ELECTION OF KAVANAUGH AND
THE CARAVAN.
KAVANAUGH WE UNDERSTAND BECAUSE
OF FAIRNESS AND DUE PROCESS AND
MEN FEEL LIKE THEY'RE BEING
TARGETED UNFAIRLY.
WHY IS THIS CARAVAN IMPORTANT
BOTH TO MEXICO AND THE UNITED
STATES?
>> THE CARAVAN BRINGS TO VIVID
ATTENTION THAT THE FEINSTEIN
OPEN BORDERS BILL AND THE
ATTITUDE ABOUT IMMIGRATION ARE
SUCH BIG DANGERS ABOUT THE
COUNTRY.
AND THERE ARE 179 MILLION PEOPLE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO COME TO THE
U.S.
>> WELL, OUR COUNTRY IS 320
MILLION, RIGHT?
>> AND WHAT WE HAVE TO CONFRONT
IS EXACTLY WHAT THAT MEXICAN
OFFICIAL SAID.
IF WE'RE NOT PREPARED TO STOP
THIS CARAVAN, HOW BIG WILL THE
NEXT ONE BE, AND HOW MANY WILL
THERE BE.
THEY DON'T LIKE TO CONTROL THE
BORDER AND STOP IMMIGRATION.
IN FACT, STACY ABRAMS, THE
DEMOCRAT CANDIDATE FROM THE
GOVERNOR OF A GAH --
SAN FRANCISCO PASSED A RULE THAT
ALLOWS PEOPLE HERE ILLEGALLY TO
VOTE.
>> DEVASTATING IMAGES.
LOOK AT THESE IMAGES.
THEY'RE DEVASTATING.
>> YOU TALK ABOUT MOBS VERSUS
JOBS.
YOU'RE SEEING EXACTLY THE KIND
OF MOB BEHAVIOR THAT THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE LED TO.
>> BUT TWO BLOCKS FROM HERE,
NEWT, THERE'S A HOMELESS
SHELTER.
ANY GIVEN NIGHT, THERE ARE
INDIVIDUALS OUTSIDE WAITING TO
GET IN.
THERE ARE NOT ENOUGH BEDS.
THEY'RE ON THE STREETS.
THEY'RE DESTITUTE.
MANY OF THEM FORMER MILITARY.
THEY'RE VETERANS, DOWN ON THEIR
LUCK, SOMEWHERE MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES, SOME NOT.
THEY'RE JUST DOWN ON THEIR LUCK.
THEY GIVE TO VARIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS, INTERNATIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HELP CHILDREN
IN NEED, INCLUDING IN CENTRAL
AMERICA, LIKE FOOD FOR THE POOR,
ALL THESE GREAT ORGANIZATIONS.
THEY SAY, LOOK, WE HAVE A LOT OF
PROBLEMS HERE.
WE'RE COMPASSIONATE PEOPLE.
WE DO NOT WANT TO FEEL LIKE
WE'RE BAD OR HORRIBLE PEOPLE
BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT TO SAY,
ANYONE WHO WANTS TO COME IN CAN
COME IN.
BUT WHEN YOU SEE THESE PICTURES
THIS IS THE PROOF OF WHAT NO
CONSEQUENCES FOR CROSSING INTO
OUR COUNTRY ILLEGALLY WILL
BRING.
THESE INDIVIDUALS, YOU CAN'T
EVEN BLAME THEM.
THEY KNOW IF THEY GET A FOOTHOLD
INTO THE UNITED STATES, WHAT
HAPPENED.
>> THIS IS AN INVASION.
THIS IS AN ACT OF ATTACKING THE
UNITED STATES' SOVEREIGNTY.
>> AND I WANT TO THANK THE
MEXICAN OFFICIALS AND THE
MEXICAN POLICE WHO ARE PUTTING
THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE AND
GETTING A LOT OF GRIEF FOR
LEFTIST POLITICIANS.
>> I THINK ACTUALLY THIS IS THE
BEST MEXICO'S EVER BEEN.
>> EVER.
>> BUT ALSO I THINK THE --
YOU CAN'T HAVE THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE DECIDING TO BREAK THE LAW
AND HAVE ANY EXPECTATION AND
CIVILIZATION IS GOING TO
WITHSTAND IT.
>> I WANT TO HEAR FROM MIKE
POMPEO ADDRESSING THE ISSUE OF
WOMEN AND CHILDREN BEING USED AS
A HUMAN SHIELD.
LET'S WATCH.
>> THIS IS A LARGE GROUP OF
PEOPLE.
THEY ARE PUTTING WOMEN AND
CHILDREN IN FRONT OF THE CARAVAN
TO USE AS SHIELDS AS THEY MAKE
THEIR WAY THROUGH.
THIS IS AN ORGANIZED EFFORT TO
COME THROUGH AND VIOLATE THE
SOVEREIGNTY OF MEXICO.
AND SO ALTHOUGH WE --
ABOUT HOW THEY'RE GOING TO
ADDRESS THIS VERY SERIOUS AND
IMPORTANT ISSUE TO THEIR
COUNTRY.
>> THEY HAVE EMBRACED OPEN
BORDERS.
THEY HAVE WELCOMED IN
LOW-SKILLED WORKERS, LOW-WAGE
WORKERS.
AS HAVE SOME REPUBLICANS.
LET'S BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT THIS
OTHER THE YEARS.
IT KEEPS WAGES DOWN AND A LOT OF
BUSINESSES ARE HAPPY WITH THAT.
THEY GET CHEAP LABOR, PAY THEM
CASH.
AND IT'S GOOD FOR SOME OF THESE
CONSTRUCTION WORK CREWS IN D.C.,
MOST OF THEM SPEAKING SPANISH,
HARDWORKING PEOPLE.
BUT IT HAS HURT AMERICAN
INDUSTRIES FROM LANDSCAPING AND
PLUMBING, THE LIST GOES ON.
>> I THINK THE WHOLE IMAGERY
THAT YOU NOW HAVE THESE PEOPLE,
FIRST OF ALL, THEY'RE POLITICAL
ACTIVISTS.
THEY'RE NOT REFUGEES.
YOU RAISED THE QUESTION LAST
WEEK, WHO'S PAYING FOR ALL THIS?
THIS HAS GONE FROM 3,000 TO NOW
WE THINK 5,000 PEOPLE.
IT TAKES $7,000 A PERSON.
WHO'S PAYING FOR IT?
AND BY THE WAY, IF IT'S AN
AMERICAN GROUP PAYING SOMEBODY
TO BREAK THE LAW, THAT'S CALLED
AIDING AND ABETTING AND THAT'S A
CRIME.
>> THE LUTHERAN AND CATHOLIC
CHURCH DOES GET ABOUT $90
MILLION TO RESETTLE MIGRANTS IN
THE UNITED STATES.
SO A LOT OF THE MIGRANTS ACROSS
THE BORDER, WE CAN'T KEEP THEM,
WE DON'T HAVE ANY HOUSING.
THEY DID A GREAT REPORT ON THIS
YESTERDAY.
AND THEN THEY'RE TRANSPORTED ALL
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES,
SHELTERS PAID FOR BY THE
CATHOLIC CHURCH, LUTHERAN
CHURCH, OTHER ORGANIZATIONS.
SO THERE'S AN INTERESTING
REVOLVING DOOR OF CASH FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO THESE
NGO'S AND 501C3'S.
LET'S WATCH THE PRESIDENT IN
MESA.
>> RIGHT NOW, AS YOU KNOW,
MEXICO IS ON THEIR SOUTHERN
BORDER.
THEIR SOUTHERN BORDER.
AND THEY'RE FIGHTING.
AND THEY'RE FIGHTING SOME BAD
PEOPLE IN THAT GROUP.
YOU SEE THE PEOPLE COME UP AND
YOU LISTEN TO THE FAKE NEWS BACK
THERE AND YOU THINK THEY'RE ALL
--
YOU THINK THEY'RE ALL WONDERFUL
PEOPLE, RIGHT?
NO, NO.
YOU THINK -- I'M SERIOUS.
YOU THINK THEY'RE ALL WONDERFUL
PEOPLE.
YOU'VE GOT SOME BAD PEOPLE IN
THOSE GROUPS.
YOU'VE GOT SOME TOUGH PEOPLE IN
AND I'LL TELL YOU WHAT, THIS
COUNTRY DOESN'T WANT THEM.
OKAY?
>> AND I THINK, AGAIN, AMERICA
IS A WELCOMING COUNTRY.
WE LOVE MERIT-BASED LEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
TRUE REFUGEES, A LOT OF
CHRISTIANS IN THE MIDDLE EAST
WHO HAVE A HARD TIME GETTING
HERE, TRYING TO GET THE VISA
LOTTERY, WHICH A LOT OF US WANT
TO DO AWAY WITH.
BUT HE'S RIGHT.
AMERICA SEES THIS HAS GOTTEN
TOTALLY OUT OF CONTROL AND IT'S
JUST A QUESTION OF FAIRNESS TO
THE AMERICAN WORKER.
>> IT'S ALSO A QUESTION OF
FAIRNESS TO PEOPLE WHO HAVE
OBEYED THE LAW.
>> WE ACCEPT MORE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS THAN ANY COUNTRY IN
THE WORLD.
THOSE FOLKS OBEYED THE LAW.
THEY LOOK AT SOMEBODY WHO'S
BREAKING THE LAW.
AND THERE'S A RESENTMENT OF WHY
ARE THESE PEOPLE ABLE TO BREAK
THE LAW.
>> FORMER OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIAL ON CNN TALKING ABOUT
JOB GROWTH.
SPEAKING OF THE MIDTERMS, I WANT
TO PLAY THIS.
>> THE JOB GROWTH HAS BEEN THE
CASE FOR SIX YEARS.
THE JOB GROWTH WAS ACTUALLY
BETTER IN THE LAST YEAR OF THE
OBAMA PRESIDENCY THAN THE FIRST
YEAR OF THE TRUMP POLICY.
SO HE'S BENEFITING FROM THAT.
>> IT WAS BETTER UNDER OBAMA.
>> SHE HAD A BETTER JOB UNDER
OBAMA.
LET'S START WITH HER.
I THINK SHE HAD A BETTER JOB.
LOWEST AFRICAN-AMERICAN
UNEMPLOYMENT IN HISTORY.
LOWEST LATINO EMPLOYMENT IN
HISTORY.
IT'S PRETTY HARD NOT TO BELIEVE
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS
POLICIES HAVE MADE A VERY
POSITIVE IMPACT.
THE ONLY MAJOR ECONOMY THAT'S
GROWING RIGHT NOW IS THE UNITED
STATES.
NONE OF THE OTHERS ARE GROWING.
AND I THINK THAT WE'RE DOING
SOMETHING RIGHT.
BUT I ALSO THINK IT COMES BACK
TO THIS QUESTION, WE WANT TO BE
A COUNTRY THAT IS WELCOMING TO
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO BECOME
AMERICANS.
AND WE WANT TO BECOME A COUNTRY
THAT'S WELCOME
THAT'S WELCOING TO PEOPLE WHO
WANT TO OBEY THE LAW AND PLAY BY
THE RULES.
AND I THINK THIS WHOLE NOTION OF
JOBS VERSUS MOBS IS REAL.
AND YOU'VE SEEN IT HERE AT HOME
WITH DEMOCRATIC MOBS.
YOU'RE SEEING IT NOW WITH A MOB.
AND THIS IS A VERY SERIOUS
QUESTION.
YOU'VE HAD SOME VERY STRANGE
COMMENTS.
THE SENATOR FROM VIRGINIA WHO
SAID WE OUGHT TO BE PUNCHING AND
FIGHTING IN THE STREETS.
THE FORMER ATTORNEY GENERAL SAID
WE OUGHT TO BE KICKING
REPUBLICANS.
>> HILLARY SAYING WE CAN'T BE
CIVIL UNTIL WE WIN AGAIN.
BECAUSE THEY WERE SO CIVIL BACK
THEN.
>> WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE THAT
PEOPLE NEED TO TAKE A DEEP
BREATH AND ASK THEMSELVES WHAT
KIND OF AMERICA DO YOU WANT TO
LIVE IN, AND YOU REALLY WANT TO
LIVE IN AN AMERICA WHERE MOBS
ARE GOING TO COME INTO YOUR
RESTAURANT TO DRIVE YOU OUT OF
IT.
IS THAT REALLY WHAT YOU'RE
COMFORTABLE WITH?
>> I'M BEGGING THEM TO DO THAT
TO ME.
BRING IT.
THAT'S ALL I CAN SAY.
THIS IS PRESIDENT TRUMP TONIGHT
SPEAKING ABOUT WHAT AMERICA
ULTIMATELY OVER TIME TURNS INTO
IF THIS CONTINUES.
LET'S WATCH.
>> THEY WILL TRY TO PLUNGE OUR
COUNTRY INTO A NIGHTMARE OF
POVERTY AND CHAOS.
YOU KNOW THAT.
IT'S GOING TO BE A MESS.
DEMOCRATS WANT TO RAISE YOUR
TAXES, IMPOSE SOCIALISM ON OUR
COUNTRY, TURN US INTO A
VENEZUELA, TURN US INTO ANOTHER
VENEZUELA.
>> NOW, THAT'S JUST AN
OVERSTATEMENT?
>> NO, I DON'T THINK SO.
FOR EXAMPLE, THE DEMOCRATS SAY
THEY WANT TO HAVE UNIVERSAL
HEALTHCARE FOR EVERYBODY.
AND IN CALIFORNIA, THE GOVERNOR
SAYS HE WOULD GIVE IT AWAY TO
EVERY ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT THAT
SHOWED UP.
WELL, IF WORD WENT OUT
WORLDWIDE, GET TO CALIFORNIA AND
THEY'LL TAKE CARE OF YOUR
HEALTHCARE, THE SHEER COST OF
THAT WOULD BREAK THE AMERICAN
SYSTEM.
AND I THINK WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND, THESE ARE FOLKS WHO
DON'T HAVE A CLUE ABOUT THE REAL
WORLD.
WHAT THEY'RE FOCUSED ON IS
POWER.
THEY WANT POWER OVER YOU AND ME.
THEY WANT POWER TO DEFINE HOW
WE'RE ALLOWED TO BEHAVE, NOTHING
ABOUT CREATING JOBS AND NOTHING
ABOUT ECONOMIC GROWTH.
>> THE DEMOCRATS TODAY ARE ALL
UP IN ARMS BECAUSE OF PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S COMMENTS LAST NIGHT
ABOUT THE FORTE, HE'S MY KIND OF
POLITICIAN.
THIS IS AT A TIME WHEN KHASHOGGI
WAS MURDERED AT THE CONSULATE IN
TURKEY AND THE PRESIDENT IS
SENDING A TERRIBLE MESSAGE ABOUT
FREEDOM OF THE PRESS AT A TIME
WHERE THE PRESS WAS ATTACKED
OBVIOUSLY IN THIS MURDER.
>> YES, AND I THINK THAT THE
PRESS WILL ALWAYS BE HIGHLY
SENSITIVE.
YOU DON'T NOTICE WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT HOW DANGEROUS IT GETS, HOW
OFTEN THE PRESS ARE PREPARED TO
SAY THERE WAS THE REPUBLICAN
WHIP STEVE SCALISE WHO WAS SHOT,
THAT IT WAS A REPUBLICAN
HEADQUARTERS IN NEW YORK THAT
ANTIFA DESTROYED.
YOU DON'T SEE MUCH UNDERSTANDING
IN THE PRESS ABOUT THE LEVEL OF
OPPRESSION FROM THE LEFT.
>> CASIN
>> CASTRO IS A CONGRESSMAN FROM
SAN ANTONIO.
HE SAID THIS ABOUT KUSHNER.
>> THE REPORTING THAT KUSHNER
MAY HAVE WITH U.S. INTELLIGENCE
DELIVERED A HIT LIST, AN ENEMIES
LIST TO A CROWNED PRINCE AND
THAT THE PRINCE MAY THEN HAVE
ACTED ON THAT AND ONE OF THE
PEOPLE THAT HE TOOK ACTION
AGAINST IS MR. KHASHOGGI.
>> SO HE ORDERED A HIT?
>> THAT COMMENT IS INSANE,
LITERALLY INSANE.
THE FACT IS KHASHOGGI IS A
PUBLIC FIGURE.
EVERYBODY IN SAUDI ARABIA KNEW
WHO HE WAS.
THE IDEA THAT AN AMERICAN HAD TO